yes because women like easy Majors we
want to go and get degrees in Psychology
philosophy all this ass degrees
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series today we are going to be
talking about why the wage Gap doesn't
exist so I used to be a big Turning
Point fan with the whole YouTube thing I
don't actually watch too much YouTube
anymore so it'll be interesting to like
re-watch some of these old videos I'm
Alex Clark and in 180 seconds I'm going
to convince you that the gender wage Gap
doesn't exist
tonight
the popular and commonly stated notion
that women make less than men is often
skewed misrepresented and misunderstood
and yeah because women like complain yes
I will die on them so women are making
less money than men but you know what
this isn't because of sex as business
owners or due to a systemically
patriarchal society in fact the Equal
Pay Act of 1963 prevents businesses from
paying women any less on the basis thank
you Alex thank you I'm gonna use this
next debate so how did this distorted
data become the most frequently cited
evidence of workplace inequality amongst
the women's rights movement the reason
is rooted in the oversimplification of
wage calculations the source study only
compares the total median earnings of
men versus women it doesn't take into
account the job the amount of hours
worked the industry or any work versus
Life Choices women are also more likely
to take time off or not work at all due
to family response ability yeah I would
hope because we're supposed to be moms I
mean if you're not gonna take time off
for your kids it's like what kind of mom
are you when surveyed 27 of mothers said
they had quit work altogether and four
in ten mothers said that they had taken
a significant amount of time off or
reduced their work hours to care for a
child or another family member compared
to the 24 of fathers that said the same
thing comparing the majors that men
choose versus those of women yes because
women like easy Majors we want to go and
get degrees in Psychology philosophy all
this ass degrees and make no
money at the end of it and again to
hundreds of thousands of dollars worth
of debt and then wine about our life
choices hours we see a good indication
of these career choice differences
starting at the educational level data
from the U.S Department of Education
shows that the average salary for the 10
most popular Majors by women is at 52.8
000 while the average salary for the 10
most popular majors by men is 62 000.
that's almost a ten thousand dollar
difference and what percent of women
want to do construction what percent of
women want to be plumbers electricians
and these differences in career choices
you shouldn't be shamed but supported
these differences do not hurt our
society they complement it despite what
many people believe women in America are
doing great and are more successful in
some areas than men hey since his data
from his earliest 2008 shows that single
childless women in their 20s are making
more money than their male counterparts
yeah because we can monetize Beauty
that's the other thing women we think
we're like such hot because you
know we monetize our Beauty I mean even
me like I'm in entertainment in a way I
mean you guys you guys dog on me
sometimes but in a way it's like it's
monetizing Beauty and like let's look at
the women doing only fans even in front
facing sales front like customer facing
jobs it monetizes Beauty women we really
have no idea how much better the world
treats us because we for women we really
don't and one day you get to be 50 and
you're damn near invisible to man and
you don't get all the special treatment
and yeah and then you're gonna miss it
yup eight percent the competition of
free market capitalism puts pressure on
businesses and business owners to hire
and promote those who are best fit for
the job regardless of gender we
shouldn't be manipulating wage
statistics in order to support a
political agenda we should be supporting
policies that reward hard work and
dedication for everyone regardless of
gender and allow the free market to do
what it does best create a fair and
strong Workforce I'm Alex Clark and I
just convinced you that the gender wage
Gap is a myth in 180 seconds boom wow
boom Oh my gosh I miss conservative
media it has been a minute since I
watched this stuff because back in the
day okay the people that get it get it
it was like Jordan Peterson Ben Shapiro
if I had to do my hall of fame for
conservative media Jordan Peterson Ben
Shapiro Candice Owens she's a Hall of
Famer Thomas Sowell I'm sorry but I'm
open to suggestions I could change it
let me know in the comments who are your
top five conservative media choices like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel and I'll talk to you next
time